do you remember kyle rittenhouse
cal rittenhouse was this young man who
during the blm riots went out and tried
to put it you know put out some fires as
there were arsonists running rough shot
and people destroying property and
threatening people and killing people
and when some of the antifa lunatics
came after him he shot them in
self-defense
it would seem i mean we have videos of
these things it looks like he shot them
in self defense
so
they're trying to prosecute him
he's a young evil white guy conservative
i mean he checks every box for throw
this guy in jail and throw away the key
the prosecution is is really going after
him
and
as the trial begins the judge
actually is mocking
the prosecution for their ridiculous
ideology
if there were any evidence in this case
and i would i would love to hear that i
haven't seen it if there was any
evidence in this case that mr rosenbaum
physically attacked anyone else that
night
chased anyone else that night assaulted
anyone else that night threatened
anybody with a weapon that night
we can talk about that but i don't hear
any evidence to that effect all we're
talking about is arson we're talking
about being loud and disorderly we're
talking about you know being i can't
believe some of the things you're seeing
and what you're writing talking about is
arson come on
i love that judge at the end all you're
talking about is arson come on i mean
this guy this prosecutor here is he is
the guy from msnbc they're not literally
the same guy but it's the exact same
point you remember the guy from msnbc
he's standing in front of a burning
building he's saying these are fiery but
mostly peaceful protests i would say
other than the arson and the looting and
the mugging and the beating and the
murdering it's mostly uh peaceful so if
you can show me
judge
that these guys you know we're doing
anything other than uh burn and pillage
and kill and steal and if you anything
else
okay then um then we then we can have
that conversation
in the kyle rittenhouse trial as the
prosecutors are talking to the judge and
trying to get this kid thrown in prison
forever
for
what would seem to be defending himself
the
the
prosecution is attempting to frame the
debate and we know that whoever frames
the issue wins the debate so
what the prosecution is trying to do is
say that the people that kyle
rittenhouse shot
were victims now of course rittenhouse's
point is no no they were coming after me
they were chasing me these are very
violent people they were burning stuff
down and i shot them in self-defense and
what the prosecution wants to do is call
them
victims the judge having none of it
this is bad character evidence your
honor this is an attempt to tell the
jury mr rosenbaum's a bad guy and
deserve to die that's really what it is
he was an arsonist he was a rioter he
was starting fights or was not starting
fights he was starting problems he was
disorderly he was loud he was uh
whatever
this is really bad stuff your honor okay
you're what you're doing is you're
prejudicing the jury against
the person that i'm representing just
because he was a filthy degenerate
criminal who was burning stuff down and
committing crimes in the moment and was
chasing this kid who then shot him in
self-defense
okay
judge that's that's so wrong
now of course
what the prosecution is trying to do
is and actually the judge just shot this
down is bring up a bunch of other
problems that kyle rittenhouse had had
that were not related to this to this
moment but
in this prevailing
ideology
the if you are
a
white certainly just heard it from that
professor a white
conservative oh my gosh that's awful
that's probably worst of all
if you're because you can be black and a
conservative and if you're a black
conservative you're a white supremacist
they do that to candace all the time or
larry elder or anybody
so if you're a white conservative male
straight
you know you are presumed guilty until
proven innocent and even if you shoot
someone in self-defense that is not
permitted and the force of the state
will come after you
did you like that clip
i i liked that clip as well i liked that
you liked it if you want to get these
notifications you've got to ring the
bell and subscribe you still probably
won't get notifications because some
people around here don't
particularly care for our show
youtube but you can also subscribe at
apple podcast but if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe to the michael knowles
show
click that button maybe leave a
five-star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you